well we begin this bulletin with
breaking news out of nigeria
there are reports that gunmen have
kidnapped students from a college there
that abduction happened in kaduna state
in the northwest
school attacks have become much more
frequent of late
with the most recent of them being a
mass abduction
of 279 pupils in zamfara state
last month we'll be getting you more on
all of this
as we get it and in fact right now we
can speak to fidelis mba
he's a journalist joining us on the
phone now from the nigerian capital
abuja fidelis what do we know about this
latest abduction they seem to be coming
thick and fast well the latest abduction
uh
happened in the earlier friday and that
so far the government has not made any
official statement
as to the number of people who were
kidnapped or those who were behind the
kidnapping
the school authorities have also not
issued any statement we're still
waiting for the military authorities to
also issue a statement
as for uh these those kidnapped the
girls were taking from
its ecology a higher institution of
learning in cardinal state which is just
a few kilometers from the nation's
capital abuja
and this is like the first time that
this kidnapping is happening
that mass abduction of girls is
happening in a higher institution of
learning
the men have always targeted secondary
schools where younger girls attend
but this is a higher institution of
learning and uh
this is more like a new development from
their
mode of operation and so far what we
know is that
the kidnapping happened this morning but
how many people were taking
and which group has been behind this
kidnapping
has not been made public yet fidelis
we're watching pictures now
of some of the girls were released from
another abduction
i mean in the last few weeks now
obviously we've been seeing multiple
school attacks over the course of the
last few weeks and months
how are people there feeling about the
security situation
i know there was a lot of anger to begin
with
well there's been anger about the
security situation in the country
especially in recent months where
abduction not just of school girls or
school boys has increased
we've also had passengers and commercial
buses been taking
people in private vehicles been taking a
long major highway
which is why recently the government
announced
a change in the top military hierarchy
by
changing the defense chiefs but then
since this happened there's been
still an increase in the number of
abductions
actually the government has said that
these are like
more the the armed people and
men are targeting soft spots because
they've been pushed
away from their location but at this
time now people are really worried
as to what government is doing to ensure
that these kidnappings
are not no longer as frequent as it's
been in the last few days
fidelity with all the latest for us from
abuja in nigeria thank you so much for
dallas